im Rahmen eines vom heeressportzentrum
organisierten Trainingslagers in und ums
niederösterreichische Siebenstein
durften sich die Stars der
rot-weiß-roten Biathlon
Nationalmannschaft zuletzt ganz
besonderen Herausforderungen stellen
so lud eine Eliteeinheit des
österreichischen Bundesheeres das
legendäre Jagdkommando die Skijägerinnen
unter einigen anderen zu wahrlich
gezielten Schuss Sessions inklusive
spannenden Lektionen in Sachen train
your brain und zu einer heftigen
autoübung zur Stärkung des teamspirits
in der Wildnis rund um die ganze Kaserne
Sport passt Austria Robert natürlich
nicht
[Musik]
im Hochleistungssport ist die
Leistungsdichte der Athleten und
Athleten schon sehr eng beieinander und
der Zweck dieser Übung ist Jena dass wir
nun Wert durch neue reizsetzungen
versuchen diese Qualität der Athletinnen
und Athleten zu verbessern bei Biathlon
handelt es sich um eine
schwerpunktsportart des österreichischen
Bundesheeres und somit greifen wir auf
Ressourcen des Jahres zurück im
konkreten heißt es dass wir auf die
Spezialeinsatzkräfte des
österreichischen Bundesheeres das ja
Kommando zurückgreifen und hier werden
wir durch neue
Schießübungen Einsatzübungen des Jahres
die an die Biathleten weitergegeben
werden diese neue reizenzungen umsetzen
und das führt dann dazu dass
dementsprechend durch diese neuen
dreizehnungen bessere Leistungen auch
spezifisch erzielt werden können
[Musik]
größte Unterschied natürlich bei
sturmwaren bei unseren Kleinkaliber
Gewehr ist glaube ich wo einfach hart
ist ganze das ist für grobe ist was wir
jetzt gerade machen da haben es ist
natürlich für uns schon richtig cool
wenn man das jetzt mal wieder versuchen
darf wir machen das zwar einmal im Jahr
ein und dann ja wir sind jetzt doch
einiges sorgt wir haben bei der innen
sehr viel Augentraining schon Kopfweh
das ist für uns aber total wertvoll und
ich glaube das weiß ich ja Anwendung
finden bei uns
[Musik]
erster Linie das für uns eine ganz
großen Eis ist und natürlich für stärker
als Kaliber also große Herausforderung
schierstand und man merkt natürlich dass
viel mehr Wumms einfach dahinter ist und
da ist natürlich Respekt vor der Woche
leer geschossen Magazin wieder abnehmen
vor miteinander verbunden das was wir
heute erleben ist das unsere Elitetruppe
das ja Kommando gemeinsam mit der Elite
aus dem Sport in die Athleten
miteinander Teambuilding macht das hilft
beiden Seiten das ist so viel was
verbindet äh Leistungsbereitschaft
Einsatzbereitschaft die da ist man lernt
auch sich zu konzentrieren und die Teams
auch richtig zusammen zu stellen das
muss man öfter machen
und ich bin überzeugt davon das hilft
der
[Musik]
das Besondere war dann auch dass man
eigentlich viel Rechenaufgaben kriegt
haben dass man für den Kopf aber es
machen muss und dann nehmen aber nur die
anderen Sachen lösen und es ist einfach
es ist viel Input das von außen kommt
und was man halt irgendwie dann unter
den Hut bringen muss und ich glaube dass
dieser fürs gehirner kurz Training ist
gestern haben wir ja so Übungen gemacht
mit mit Visualisierung und
ich glaube das ist für schießen ganz von
Nutzen sein kann weil es soll einfach in
dem Moment sein muss und Aufgaben lösen
muss aber Adern zusätzlich noch deine
Bewegungen hast die ist ausführen musst
und ja auf jeden Fall kann ich sehr viel
davon mitnehmen
irgendwo im Umkreis von 50 m muss ich
hier Trainer befinden
finden
[Musik]